on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-hander kevin gausman
gaza 30 years old he's in his eighth
year at the big league level
eight two with a one six eighty area and
all that has done is put him on the
all-star team 116 strikeouts 101 innings
so here is dylan carlson
looking up into the bright sunshine is
flores and he was battling the wind and
the sun there
and olin aronado 16 homers 52 batted in
he's also had 25
doubles
that ball into deep left that one
is way back there and caught at the wall
by estrada who has very little outfield
experience
but he went right back to the wall timed
his leap
and caught it nadia molina
will turn 39 in eight days
hall of famer i think the the day of the
all-star game is his birthday
[Music]
struck him out the inning is over
[Applause]
kwang hong kim the lefty gets a start
for the cardinals today
six road games number seven today he's
owned four
era is under five
estrada nice play to his left sosa
robbing estrada of a base hit
still wanted two
struck him out one out nobody on
strikes recall and that's the beauty of
a great split once you establish that
pitch it is in the back of everybody's
mind but i know as soon as he gets back
on the mount hopefully it's
in the game today he's going to forget
all that stuff he's so mentally tough
kim makes the play
and gets solano that's a very good play
by kk
could be two four six three with the
double play
do it to the count to carlson only 22
years old
and that is all for him fourth strikeout
the wave this team over all the giants
they hammer i mean they absolutely
punish fastballs they hit it for average
hit for power get on base it's on him
one of the best fastball hitting clubs
in all of baseball
3-2 pitch runner goes and it's swung on
and missed
[Applause]
two strikeouts in the ball game two in
the inning
2-2 goldschmidt broke his bat
solano makes a catch nice play
well the degree of difficulty was about
9.5 on a scale of 10.
2-2 got it swinging
that's five strikeouts for kevin gausman
goes through the heart of the order in
order
nothing nothing
goes after the first pitch jalen davis
got a late break sprinting in and he
will dive
and catch it and it's gonna turn into a
double play
what a play by jalen davis
you gotta sell out it's exactly what he
does
carpenter the base runner had nowhere to
go and they get to
here's a 1-1 and a ground ball
on the line arenado got him what a play
nola narnado kelly downs on the mound
in saint louis ozzy ozzy hit it right
didn't ozzie smith hit the ball on the
ground at a diving stab wilbur flores
he throws him out picked out of the dirt
by darren ruff
whoa takes away not only a hit but he
takes away a double
and then on the back end darren ruff
goes to a high backhander beautiful dig
[Applause]
look at the high backhanded spear get up
quickly and then here's the other part
of the great play
this is such a difficult play just right
at the end of the web
gets up nice quick exchange the 1-2
carlson strikes out swinging just a
beautiful splitter
seven pitches cardinals go down in order
ultimate is what
popped up to second
crawford to his backhand side here's the
throw
in time he had a high target over there
with darren ruff he's a big guy
nolan aronado hit that deep fly ball to
left
in the first caught by estrada with a
jump
and flight out to shallow left his last
time
well he rips that one with another
splitter
and that is the first hit of the game
for the cardinals
giants fans responding with a standing
ovation for kevin gazman
prior to that hit the longest that
gosman has ever had
a no hitbid was four two thirds in 2017
when he was with the orioles against
boston
four and two thirds when he was with the
orioles against the angels
and four in a third when he was for the
giants against miami you can see in the
two-strike county goes down that's not a
hangar
arnott just went down and got it matt
carpenter has an rbi
opportunity with arenado the runner at
second
the 2-2 carpenter with a drive
out to center at the wall
and it's off the wall two runs will
score
carpenter digging for third in there
with a triple
two to nothing st louis on a matt
triple in the seventh great at bat for
carpenter
three hits in the inning for the
cardinals carpenter hits a triple
over the head of the center fielder
slater his first
that same pitch early in the the at-bat
he let it go
he fouled off another one at 93 mile an
hour down the way didn't look like a
pitch that he was going to be able to
get to
gets one again at 94 and hammers it off
the wall and one of the deepest parts of
the ballpark are you kidding me
this is a guy who is
chiseled like a greek god very very
strong
on the third base side backhanded by
flores the long throw
handled by darren ruff out number two
arnado lifts a fly ball into shallow
right
and that's down for a hit a run will
score
that'll make it three to nothing
goldschmidt to third and all this being
done
with two outs here in the top of the
eighth as nolan drives in his
53rd of the year three nothing cardinals
so here is a third pinch hitter
dickerson as the giants
use all of their available left-handed
hitters
second baseman sosa and shallow right
field in the overshift
de young now at shortstop
that's into deep right field that's on
its way
it's a home run off the hands of a fan
and ruled a home run by john tompane
the umpire at first for the giants first
run of the game
i'm sure they're going to take a look at
this or at least talk about it oh that's
a hard run
that's a home run all it's got to do is
hit the 10 roof even if it's in the
front
one ball and two strikes ohtani might
hit some balls pretty deep in colorado
too
derby hit up the middle that's a base
hit off the bat of vader
another run will score tommy edmond back
to a three-run lead and it's 4-1
[Applause]
that's a blue base hit
so flores will trot home
and that makes brandon crawford the
possible tying run of the game
and he ended on pitch number 20 here in
the bottom of the ninth
the o2 swing and a miss he struck him
out
and the cardinals take game one of the
series in san francisco the final of
five to three